welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and 2023 promises major titles we
cannot wait to dive into here at new
rockstars guanamania and the start of
Marvel phase five the Mandalorian The
Last of Us and a ton of great other
films we actually spent the final weeks
of 2022 in a kind of creative Retreat
that we've never done before to make
plans for how we're gonna cover all of
this and the plan we came up with might
be the biggest and most exciting thing
new rock stars has ever done so let's
pop on our Kevin hat and break down the
sleigh e-r-i-k stands for emphatic
robotic indulgent know it all so here's
what you can expect on new rockstars in
2023 actually I hate how this fits on my
head so let's get rid of that okay let's
start with what we're going to be
talking about on the channel now of
course new rockstars is best known for
our Marvel breakdowns and our theories
and of course our thumbnails that have
turned into memes but in 2022 actually
like to think we reminded people that we
break down a lot more than Marvel we
covered House of the Dragon the boys and
or Obi-Wan Kenobi Rick and Morty
Peacemaker stranger things and movies
like The Batman Black Adam gun Maverick
Avatar the way of water Glass Onion nope
and the best of all of them morbius and
you know what we still didn't get to
cover everything with the depth that we
would have wanted to so in 2023 new rock
stars is gonna aim to cover everything
if a movie ends up being number one in
the box office or some title is number
one on streaming we are gonna aim to be
the number one YouTube channel analyzing
it I mean I don't know maybe not the
first out of the gate but we will spend
that time trying to be the most thorough
so in addition to covering MCU titles
like quantumania what if season two
secret Invasion ironheart Guardians
volume 3 the Marvel's Loki season 2 and
Agatha coven of chaos to the extent that
we've always covered the MCU we are also
going to cover the last of us the
Mandalorian season three and pretty much
every franchise series with the 2023
release date like we're gonna cover
movies like Shazam area the god John
Wick chapter 4 the Super Mario Brothers
movie fast 10 Spider-Man across the
spider-verse Transformers rise of the
beasts The Flash if that movie's still
coming out Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny Mission Impossible dead
reckoning Christopher no Oppenheimer
Barbie Blue Beetle craving the hunter
Dune part 2 and Aquaman and the lost
kingdom just to name a few and yeah this
sound there's already a ton of content
on the channel as it is
later and I personally only have so much
bandwidth now that I'm you know married
and Counting Mephisto there are three in
this marriage but I will not be doing
Salon I get to work with the most
talented hosts and producers who in the
last year have stepped up and proved
themselves certainly more than I did in
my first year of doing this so let's
let's let's let's let's get started and
I realized I never properly introduced
the team to all of you so here they are
here the 90s Bulls music oh we can't use
that we'll get copyright flagged cue
some other copyright friendly music
awesome there is Jessica Clemens my old
sketch team friend a college teamer
veteran and our original inside Marvel
co-host during one division in 2022
Jessica broke down the episodes of
She-Hulk she did an incredible job with
them and has been rushing it with a
breakdown to the boys and horror films
various moving trailers and appearances
on the break room along with Rogue
Theory and inside Marvel then there's
Master tainman Mt which I also like to
think stands for master theorist this
guy shot the Moon with his Marvel
theories on the channel this year he
really is the big brain the big head
gang on inside Marvel and Rogue Theory
Mt actually joined this channel during
covid and we finally got to meet this
guy face to face last month and I can
tell you he is as lovable and is
brilliant in person as he is on screen
then there's whenever they let it him
who came to new rock stars from nerdwire
and in 2022 she did an amazing job
covering stranger things and Rick and
Morty she's a hilarious and wonderful
human being a certified animation nerd
and a mom to an adorable pug named
Pugsley amazing dog name and of course
we got Tommy bechtold one of the
funniest human beings I know who
wouldn't pass life joined me on stage
for hundreds of improv shows whom you
might have known on new rock stars as
our Wikileaks co-host host on the break
room and an acting star in his own right
who's showing up in things like Avid
Elementary and Hunters then there's Anna
vanston our resident gamer whose
breakdown to the Mario movie trailers
have been some of the most detailed
obsessed content I have ever seen on
this channel you're gonna see her a lot
more in 2023 because finally new rock
stars is going to start covering gaming
a lot more then we got our off-screen
and increasingly on-screen producers
brand and Barrick and Zach Huddleston
regular faces on the break room both
also playing huge roles behind the
scenes at new rock stars Brandon as our
director of programming and Zach is our
director of sales and both of these guys
are super smart super hilarious and they
knew me when I was a wee little College
freshman 16 years ago so they've always
been kind of Big Brothers to me now
there are even more production and
operation staff behind the scenes but
these hosts plus the growing number of
guest co-hosts are who you can expect to
see on the channel this year now I know
some of you are used to seeing just this
stupid face but these folks are even
better than I am at covering a lot of
this stuff and I am proud to share the
blue dungeon with them so extended them
the welcome that you've always given me
now we are also going to be expanding
the number and types of formats on the
channel like the way we talk about all
these IP we're going to continue doing
what we've been doing breakdowns
reactions after shows theories
explainers break room live streams but
in 2023 I think you can expect us to do
a lot more high quality breakdowns and
maybe ease back on the number of Theory
videos see every week like I think in
2022 we sufficiently saturated the
internet with Theory thumbnails like
everyone is now double thinking that
Paul Dano knows we did it everybody now
we will still make Theory videos of
course we're just gonna aim for them to
be more thought out mind-blowing instead
of you know five Theory videos on the
same subject really I think the most
exciting place that we're gonna
experiment with theories is with YouTube
shorts that's we're gonna roll out a lot
more bite size content so you never have
to leave YouTube for any other rival
platforms so you can expect to see some
great shorts on your feed real soon now
when it comes to our breakdowns we're
going to continue doing the Easter egg
breakdowns as you know and love them but
we're also going to try out some special
breakdowns that look at movies and shows
through a specific lens you saw this
recently with my Spider-Man into the
spider-verse breakdown that just looked
at the animation details so we'll do
animation breakdowns we'll do stunts and
fight choreography breakdowns maybe just
a VFX breakdown maybe an automotive
breakdown we got another fast and
furious movie coming this year for
horror movies maybe we'll just do a
breakdown that looks at the horror jump
scares and the psychological reasons why
we're scared in that moment that sounds
like a fun breakdown right also since
all of us are pretty well connected to
the film industry we're gonna start
doing some expert breakdowns like a
breakdown of a movie co-hosted by the
movie screenwriter after all Tommy is
friends with guanamania and Kang Dynasty
screenwriter Jeff loveness we can get
him on the phone right Tommy maybe we
can break down a fast 10 with a Stunt
Driver maybe a breakdown of a cross
spider-verse with an animator who knows
maybe we can do a breakdown of the
Marvels with Iman villani my interview
with her last summer was one of the
highlights of my year and that end yes
we're gonna do more in-depth interviews
on this channel one on one asking the
kind of hard-hitting but really just
nerdy questions that you don't normally
see in typical press junket interviews
but honestly the most exciting new
formats are ones we don't even know yet
because I am happy to announce we are
launching a new program called new
Rockstar's launch pad we are going to
open things up to the full new rockstars
team to pitch a new limited series to
run on the channel every month and all
of you will get to decide what gets
renewed or extended or you know never
seen again so along with all the content
we're making right now we always want to
be able to listen to your feedback be
experimental and try to come up with the
next big thing now new rockstars will be
doing most of this out of our Burbank
office which is a bustling mad house of
content and inner office bits I don't
know how work gets done here and I am
going to be in and out of there as I
work for my home studio here in San
Francisco but we're taking things on the
road too you're gonna be able to meet us
in person because after a few successful
live events in 2022 new rock stars in
2023 plans to attend as many fests in
cons as we can we're talking the various
Comic Cons things like WonderCon Star
Wars celebration wherever nerds and
cosplayers are gathering we want to be
there with you because honestly getting
to hang out with all of you in person
has been amazing okay so that sounds
like a lot but I have saved the biggest
announcement for last and this is
something that I've been working on for
like six months now and dreaming of it
for any longer than that so with all
this content coming to the channel you
may have thought they could possibly fit
it all on one channel and you know what
you are right new rockstars has grown
too big for just one channel so we are
launching a second Channel and it is
called New rockstars the Deep dive the
Deep dive will be a side project hosted
by me but with like one to two videos a
week diving even deeper into the films
and titles that I love on a mission to
prove that what we have been calling
Easter eggs all this time are just
really the surface Sprouts of a core
root myth at the heart of every title A
subconscious narrative buried deep in
the filmmaker's psyche I am really eager
to get back to the longer deep Dives
that I started on the channel back in
the early years like my Dark Knight deep
dive where I got to dig into things like
Game Theory or my breakdown of the
Matrix where I explored existentialist
philosophy I just want to do one big
film Nerd movie analysis for you guys
every week because basically nowadays I
have to remove like 40 to 50 of every
breakdown I do because new rockstars is
like uh it's gonna take us another week
to edit this so I've been saving all
that for this new channel and it's not
just gonna be Marvel movies and other
popcorn movies though I will be deep
diving into those too don't worry but
also I'm gonna explore the cult
favorites and Prestige films that I've
always wanted to cover on new rock stars
but I've never had a chance to now to be
clear I am not leaving to rockstars I am
still going to be doing Easter egg
breakdowns and explainers and Theory
videos and after shows here on the main
Channel I'm just also going to have this
side project of the Deep dive for those
of you who want to go even deeper with
me so trust me if you're going to want
to subscribe to both channels and we got
a little treat for you the new channels
teaser
foreign
Easter eggs break down check check audio
check okay looks good
three two one welcome back to
hell
[Music]
what even is an Easter egg
foreign
[Music]
you can actually watch this teaser video
over on the Deep dive Channel which is
live now but it's going to officially
launch on February 17 2023. you can go
ahead and subscribe if you like because
I'm telling you on launch day there's
gonna be quite a bit of great content
that all hits you at once so go ahead
subscribe to the Deep dive youtube.com
deepdive NR and follow Deep dive NR on
Twitter Instagram and Tick Tock and you
can expect more details soon so there
you have it I gotta be honest I I was
scared for years I didn't know if I
could really pull this off I still don't
really know if I can pull it off but
here's what I'm comforted by I'm lucky
that I get to work with some of the most
amazing people people that many of you
have got to know and love and I'm
excited for even more people to get to
know and love them I've never felt more
excited and more confident about this
company's future and it's all because of
them so with your help 2023 is going to
be great we're gonna have a new channel
the Deep dive hosted by Yours Truly
meanwhile on the main new rockstars
Channel I'm also going to continue
joining this Stellar lineup of hosts to
analyze even more hit movies and shows
and gaming with new formats like shorts
special breakdowns expert breakdowns
interviews and new experimental mini
series coming from the launch pad every
month all of this while we take this
show on the road to party with you guys
in person we're gonna have a pretty full
plate but we got a great team in place
and we're gonna take this year to learn
and to grow and continue to try to
invite movie fans on the internet to
appreciate the deeper reasons to like
art instead of finding reasons to tear
it down as Phil Seymour Hoffman says and
Camera Crow is Almost Famous the only
currency in this bankrupt world is what
you share with someone else when you're
uncool and new rockstars is proud to
join a small group of nerds online who
never felt cool once in our lives as we
share what we love about what we love so
subscribe to new rockstars and to Deep
dive in our follow new rockstars on
social media you can also follow the
Deep dive on Twitter Instagram and Tick
Tock at Deep dive NR embrace yourself
for a year full of great content from
the new rockstars Network and lastly
thank you to all of you for helping us
grow to this point we couldn't have done
it without you so together let's go
[Music]
thank you